المنزل الذي جرفته الحياة دمرت
يوم الأحد أكثر من 70 شخصًا لقوا حتفهم
وأكثر من عشرة في عداد المفقودين بعد هطول
أمطار غزيرة أدت إلى انهيارات أرضية
وفيضانات في جميع أنحاء ولاية هيماشال براديش الشمالية في الهند.
في هذا الفيديو، يُسمع رجل يردد يا
رب، يا رب، مصدوم لأن هذه
مياه الفيضانات  تتدفق
عمليات البحث والإنقاذ في الوادي
منذ محاولة يائسة
لتحديد مكان الناجين المدفونين تحت الأنقاض الحديثة لأولئك
الذين كانوا محظوظين لأن الوزن
كان مؤلمًا،
يجب أن نستعيد أفراد عائلتنا المفقودين،
يجب أن نلقي نظرة
عليهم  في المرة الأخيرة وتحرير أرواحهم،
لم تعد لدينا أبواب مفتوحة لنا الآن،
ويجب أن نعيدهم
بمزيد من الأمطار الغزيرة في الطريق
وفقًا للتوقعات، ولا
تزال هيماشال براديش في حالة تأهب لإرسال السكان إلى
مخيمات الإغاثة،
وكانت هذه الرياح الموسمية مدمرة للولاية
منذ ذلك الحين.  مع بداية موسم الأمطار في
يونيو، توفي 300 شخص في المنطقة
وفقًا لرئيس الوزراء سوخويندر
سينغ سوكو يوم الأربعاء. أجرى سوخو
مسحًا جويًا لبعض
المناطق الأكثر تضرراً
كما هو الحال في أجزاء كثيرة من العالم
مثل هذه المواقع بسبب الظروف المناخية الشديدة.  أصبح الطقس
أكثر شيوعًا، وتشير
تقديرات جوكو إلى أن الأضرار تسببت في
خسائر تزيد عن 1.2 مليار دولار أمريكي
وقد يستغرق الأمر عامًا لإعادة بناء
البنية التحتية،
وسيحتاج بعض السكان أيضًا إلى إعادة بنائها في حياة البنية التحتية فقط
مع CNN New Delhi،
شكرًا لك